you were joined by the schools minister
nick gibb atmoscape lovely to have you
on the show this morning
um plenty of course to talk about on
your brief and we we will move to that
but i wonder if we can for just first
start with
the state of the brexit negotiations i
suppose it it depends on who you listen
to
and indeed who you believe or on the one
hand ursula wonderland
seem to be speaking quite positively
boris johnson now suggesting once again
that perhaps no deal the likeliest
outcome what's the truth of it all well
it is a very serious
situation we will test every route to
seeking a free trade agreement with the
european union
but we cannot do so at the expense of
our national sovereignty you know we
can't be the only nation on earth
uh that doesn't have control of its own
waters its own borders
we made a very clear commitment during
the referendum in the manifesto that we
would take back control of our
money our laws and our borders and that
does include the sea
and it does include making sure that in
any sort of uh
level playing field arrangement that we
we have control of our laws and those
are the red lines that the government is
negotiating we want a free trade deal
but the eu will have to move uh if we
are going to secure that deal
but just in terms of the sticking points
and you know with the greatest
of respect to those who take to the sea
to catch fish
and the british fishing industry
contributes you know less than one
percent to our
of our of our gdp is it worth
the financial impact that not getting a
trade deal will have
to essentially you know stand up for a
point of principle about
access to our waters they're not asking
for it in perpetuity
it does appear that they're asking for
just a few too many years
well it is important for an independent
sovereign nation
to have control of its its seas around
around the country that we would be the
only country in the world that didn't
but we are prepared we will do
everything we can to get a free trade
deal we'll test every route but we are
prepared
for a for no free trade deal uh
arrangements you know
liz trust has been negotiating free
trade deals around the world with
japan with canada mutual recognition
agreements united states australia new
zealand free trade agreements with
countries in
south america south korea singapore and
so on
and we are very well prepared uh we've
been preparing uh for for many many
months for
uh for life outside of a free trade
arrangement or outside
life outside the european union uh with
extra staff in hmrc
and so on and plans in place for the
board for that for our ports and so on
so
we're prepared for both eventualities
but we we are doing everything we can
to seek us a free trade agreement with
the european union of course the
the other item in the prime minister's
inbox at the moment is covert 19
and christmas um yesterday of course we
had the announcement
about various areas moving into tier
three you know come the weekend
almost 70 percent of england's
population is going to be in tier three
the tier system well at the very least
tier two
doesn't seem to work well the theater
the tier system
is a good system it means you can focus
your restrictions on areas of the
country with the highest rates of
infection we have seen
success in the northwest that's been in
tier three for weeks
we're seeing their infection rates
falling very rapidly and and we'll move
people up
tears and down tears we've moved down
tears and it seems
with a few exceptions we seem to be
moving in one direction
and that is to the highest level of to
the highest tier
on that basis you know you've got places
like greater manchester complaining well
they thought that they should come down
you know i say again with 70 with 70
of the england's population now in the
top tier how on earth is tier 2 worked
well we're seeing very serious rise in
cases 28 percent increase and just in
the last week 14
more emissions to hospitals because of
people now being in each other's company
because of the relaxation of the people
well we have to we have to
we will take action whenever uh there
are risers in infections and that's what
the tier system does and that's why matt
hancock yesterday announced further
counties going into tier three but if
you look at the r
rate we're now between point nine and
one across the uk
point between point eight and one in
england uh and if you think back to the
beginning of the pandemic when it was
over three we have achieved a huge
amount but and we are very close with
one of the first countries we are the
first country in the world to be rolling
out a vaccine 138 000 people have been
vaccinated we are very close
but we're not there yet and we cannot uh
take our foot off the accelerator in
in terms of tackling this virus and the
government will do whatever it takes
to tackle this deadly uh and virulent
uh virus that figure you mentioned there
138 000 in terms of vaccinations
that's the figure we got from the the
nadine zahavi the other day isn't it do
we
we don't yet have an updated total well
that's a that's the latest figure that's
been published so that's the thing that
i can use today
can we then talk about the testing
scheme
as regards your particular brief schools
everyone understands
that mass testing in schools will be a
key element
of us getting ourselves out of this uh
pandemic
how exactly is this going to work well
we're offering tests to
half five and a half million uh
secondary school pupils
it's about breaking the chain of
transmission following the christmas
period
so from the fourth of january um all
children will go back into primary
school
those children who are in an exam year
will start school in the 4th of january
but for the other secondary school
pupils
we will they will be learning from home
through remote education for those first
five days while schools get ready
to implement this testing regime to test
five and a half million people so
twice who will be administering the test
system within schools there was a
suggestion for a while that it was going
to be the armed forces it appears this
morning
actually teachers are going to have to
do it well the armed forces will help
with some of the planning
but the administration of the test will
be volunteers and
agency workers and there'll be some
funding for schools to help pay for
those agency workers
uh it's not about volunteers who on
earth is going to volunteer to go into
the petri dish that is our education
system at the moment and
and carry out testing well there's ppe
for available and also you know people
are very community minded this is a
national effort
to make sure that we are testing five
and a half million people so we have
more children
this is about our priority for education
making sure more children are in the
classroom
getting their lessons continuing their
education
so that in the spring and the summer we
have more students in school
rather than self-isolating when there is
a test for every positive test in a
school
on average about 24 students have to
self-isolate this is to avoid that we
want more children
in class learning continuing their
education but believe you me i am very
well of their children being
being forced to self-isolate at the
moment but but but i say it again
you have a situation in which clearly
mass testing in schools is going to be
of great importance in defeating the
pandemic
teachers get told about it on the last
full day of term the last full teaching
day of time
they are complaining that they simply do
not have the time nor the resources to
get this set up
by the time that people's return well we
announced it yesterday the 17th of
december it takes
place from the 4th of january next year
we've been piloting these tests in
schools for a number of weeks
and also on tuesday we announced that we
will be testing every
member of staff in secondary schools
once a week
and any uh any person that has a close
contact of somebody
who's tested positive in a secondary
school including the pupils will be
tested every day for seven days
and if they test negative they can
remain in school rather than
self-isolating so all these plans have
been in place but we are
acting rapidly in response to increasing
infection rates and that's the right
thing for the government to be doing
can i just speak with you absolutely
certain are teachers going to be
asked to have any role in the testing of
their pupils
no that their role is to make sure that
we continue
teaching pupils in school and also the
remote education for those first five
days from the fourth of january for
secondary school people
because the national education union
chief says that you're sending out a
video to schools a half hour video that
teachers are having to watch
and that they would be involved in this
process i just want to be absolutely
clear
teachers will have no role in this be it
you know swabbing
or carrying out the test or carrying out
the administration of the test yes
teachers are already fully occupied
in keeping the school secure in behavior
of pupils and teaching them in catch-up
and so on and remote education
they already have their hands full in
terms of the education side of what's
happening in our schools
look you know the the school system the
teachers head teachers in this country
have been magnificent during this
pandemic
uh keeping schools open helping you know
keeping those schools secure
and i take my hat off as we all do to
the work that they have been doing and
they will and i'm sure they'll respond
extremely well
to this next phase of mass testing in in
january
of course in the past few days we have
seen your boss education secretary and
and greenwich council
you know at loggerheads using
essentially the threat of legal action
to get the schools to reopen
was that entirely advisable given that
we are now instructing schools
to start making plans for not just
distance
learning and online learning but a
staggered return to school in the new
year
i mean the political capital you may
have used up with teachers
was it was it worthwhile expanding that
yes it's important
you know education is a national
priority we wanted schools we want
schools to
remain open right through to uh to the
end of term
in fact schools have delivered that 99
of schools have been open
uh since september uh with very high
attendance rates
about 85 percent attendance rates across
the system so it's not for a local
authority
to take a decision to close a school
what's happening in january
is a national decision to roll out the
mass testing of
five and a half million secondary school
students and that's why we're closed
you know why for those first five days
uh half of about half a second to school
pupils will be
having their lessons remotely at home
but then on the 11th of january they
will all
go back into school and schools will be
open primary schools secondary schools
all will be open from the fourth of
january
the head of the royal college of nursing
and dem donna canair has said that that
the relaxation at christmas
could lead to a tsunami as she describes
it
of of covert 19 cases can you just
comment on
what we've seen in northern ireland they
are going into full lockdown essentially
on boxing day
we hear reports in the times the mail
this morning about discussions about
tier four
or a national lockdown uh for the whole
of england
that's where we're heading isn't it well
nothing is ruled out of course as we
tackle this pandemic but the tier system
is a very effective way
of using test data that identifies where
the local
uh spikes in infection rates are and to
focus the restrictions on those areas so
you go into tier three if the
the infection rates are rising in
bristol and north somerset and
herefordshire we've seen
areas reduce come down the tier system
as the infection rates in those areas
are
are are coming down it is a way of
focusing the restriction and it is a
very effective system it's worked in the
north west where we've seen
of tier three area the infection rates
coming down but given what we've seen in
northern and i think we have to be
absolutely clear about this the
government is
not ruling out post-christmas a national
lockdown of the type we saw you know in
the first in the
first lockdown with the closing of
non-essential shops
restrictions or not ban on commuting
these are things that are being
discussed in government well that's not
what i said we have a very effective
uh tear system we think that the locally
focused restrictions
is a very effective way of tackling the
virus but we will do everything we can
to tackle the virus we're so close now
we've got
a vaccine 138 000 people as we discussed
uh having a vaccine with one of the
first country in the world to do that
but we cannot take the foot off the uh
the accelerator until we have tackled
this pandemic until
everybody is vaccinated that's why it's
a very good news story that we're able
to
deliver 11 million of these lateral flow
test devices to schools so five and a
half million secondary school pupils
can be tested so we can have more young
people in the classroom learning every
day in the spring term
and in the summertime leading up to
their exams in the end and the end of
the school year